[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 sur TV 78
c'est votre émission pour bien démarrer
la soirée dans les Yvelines tout de
suite les titres de ce mardi à 25 avril
la députée de la dixième circonscription
des Yvelines Aurore Bergé a lancé des
consultations citoyennes des échanges
autour de la santé de la transition
écologique et de l'école la première
réunion s'est tenue la semaine dernière
à Maurepas nous l'avons rencontré à
cette occasion interview à suivre une
idée de sortie pendant les vacances la
ville de Magny-les-Hameaux organise au
gymnase Chantal Mauduit son opération
défi sport à partir de demain au
programme des Jeux de précision de
rapidité de logique pour les plus de 6
ans nous recevrons dans cette édition
Sylvie à Danio la responsable du service
des sports de la ville enfin comme
chaque mardi une page culture retour sur
une exposition inédite le château de
Ternay à Fontenay-le-Fleury accueilli le
week-end dernier une exposition
intitulée citerne était compté mettant à
l'honneur le dramaturge et cinéaste
français Sacha à Guitry reportage à
suivre et en plateau avec nous Céline
Charles bonsoir journaliste de TV 78
vous reviendrez sur les informations du
jour à retenir dans les Yvelines en face
de vous Marion Abadie vous êtes attaché
de conservation au musée du jouet de
Poissy ensemble nous allons parler des
ateliers et animations que vous avez
proposé pendant ces vacances de
printemps dans votre structure alors
très rapidement qu'est-ce que vous allez
proposer alors on propose les ateliers
pour les enfants pour les quatre six et
pour les 7 12 grosso modo avec plein
d'activités en fait à faire en lien avec
les collections de jouets anciens de du
Musée du Jouet de Poissy alors on aura
l'occasion d'en parler à tout à l'heure
en plateau également avec nous Benjamin
Edelin vous êtes un ancien pistard de
l'équipe de France et vous avez
développé un concept pour permettre au
grand public de ressentir les sensations
d'un cycliste sur piste au Vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
est-ce que vous pouvez développer ouais
c'est ça ben en fait je le fais un petit
peu partout je l'ai fait à Saint-Quentin
mais sinon je le fais aussi de retour en
les entreprises l'idée c'est d'avoir des
vélos qui simulent un petit peu sur des
écrans c'est une sorte de simulateur en
fait qui simule le cyclisme sur piste et
aussi le cyclisme sur route c'est des
applications bien connues et là du coup
voilà il y a tout le matériel pour pour
essayer de pratiquer tous ensemble dans
les entreprises ou dans les foires dans
les animations on se fait plaisir
ensemble et c'est ultra réaliste on a pu
le tester chez ATV 78 on va passer
maintenant à la météo de demain
[Musique]
le temps sera une nouvelle fois nuageux
demain matin dans tout le département
selon Météo France au niveau des
températures il faut encore un peu frais
le matin le temps sera quasi automnale
n'hésitez pas à prendre une petite
écharpe avant de partir compter 8 degrés
ou dents et 7 degrés à Versailles
Mantes-la-Jolie Rambouillet l'après-midi
la météo va se dégrader sortez vos
parapluies et vos bottes il va pleuvoir
sur l'ensemble du département et côté
température les températures aussi entre
13 et 14 degrés dans tout le département
il faudra encore patienter quelques
jours pour pouvoir profiter pleinement
du printemps et demain nous fêterons la
sainte Alida le point maintenant sur
l'actualité du jour dans les Yvelines
on commence ces informations du jour par
cette information à une semaine de la
clôture des inscriptions pour rejoindre
les volontaires en vue des JO de Paris
2024 près de 200000 candidatures ont
déjà été déposés c'est une Charles et
oui et parmi eux seuls 45000 seront
sélectionnés pour les Jeux Olympiques
Paris 2024 l'émission seront
principalement dédiées à l'accueil près
de 10 millions de spectateurs sont
attendus pour les jeux vous pouvez
d'ailleurs toujours candidater pour être
volontaire si vous avez plus de 18 ans
au 1er janvier 2024 et parlez l'anglais
et où le français le portail
d'inscription ferme dans un peu plus
d'une semaine mercredi 3 mai la majorité
des candidats sera choisi d'ici la fin
2023 les images de la nouvelle halle du
marché de Bois-d'Arcy ont été révélées
tout à fait ce sont les arcisiens qui
ont eu le dernier mot lors de la réunion
publique du 17 avril dernier ils ont pu
voter pour leurs projets préférés parmi
deux esquisses on peut voir le résultat
final sur les images qui s'affichent la
construction majoritairement en bois se
fera 300 mètres carrés c'est le cabinet
d'architecte asseoir architecte qui s'en
chargera le marché sera situé au cœur du
quartier du vieux bourg face à l'église
Saint-Gilles le lancement des travaux
est prévu au début de l'année 2024 la
société Transdev a été désigné pour
exploiter les bus desservant le
territoire du sud-yvelines oui ce sera
pour une durée de 8 ans le groupe
Transdev assural exploitation de 129
lignes de bus des servants les communes
du Sud Yvelines comme Rambouillet ou
danse Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse ou encore
ben le contrat débutera le 1er janvier
2024 une attribution qui fera qui fait
partie de la mise en concurrence des
lignes du réseau francilien opéré par
Île-de-France mobilité ce week-end
plusieurs événements autour de la nature
et des plantes ont été organisées dans
les Yvelines on peut le dire le
département des Yvelines c'est comment
fêter le printemps à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux la prairial
faisait son retour à la Ferme du Manet
pour sa 20e édition plante décoration
produits gourmands et artisanat d'art
plus de 50 exposants étaient au
rendez-vous un événement incontournable
pour les jardiniers amateurs ou
chevronnés puisque chaque année près de
2500 visiteurs font le déplacement mais
c'est aussi une journée solidaire
écoutez cette fête a pour objectif de
collecter des fonds tous les bénéfices
de la préréal sont reversés à l'école
des chiens guides d'aveugles et finances
donc des chiens guides donc cette année
nous avons participé au financement d'un
de notre sixième chien qui a été
présenté ce matin avec sa nouvelle
maîtresse qui a été remis officiellement
à sa nouvelle maîtresse malvoyante
autre rendez-vous à Versailles cette
fois-ci 70 exposants ont pris place dans
le quartier Saint-Louis et sur le parvis
de la cathédrale pour la traditionnelle
faite esprit jardin parmi eux des
pépiniéristes des paysagistes ou encore
des artistes fleuristes au programme
également des spectacles des conférences
et plusieurs ateliers autour de la
nature menée par trois éco jardiniers de
la ville un week-end annuelle désormais
bien connu des exposants comme des
habitants écoutés j'aime beaucoup
l'ambiance de cette fête des plantes je
trouve qu'il y a une ambiance assez
conviviale assez
familiale presque je trouve qu'il y a
des belles petites animations
d'organiser pour toute la famille et du
coup c'est un rendez-vous finalement
rien que moi j'aime bien venir pour nous
c'est la première fois qu'on vient et
c'est vrai qu'on est ravi de faire
partie de cette manifestation qui
regroupe des exposants d'exception
et qui permet voilà de mettre en valeur
notre travail j'aime beaucoup les
plantes oui pour garnir mon jardin et
puis j'ai visité le potager avec
une petite animation théâtrale qui était
vraiment très très bien pour ces
prochaines portes ouvertes la SPA fait
un clin d'oeil au Festival de Cannes si
vous avez le projet d'adopter un animal
noté d'ores et déjà ces dates dans vos
agendas le 13 et 14 mai prochain toutes
les SPA de France ouvriront leur porte
au public pour présenter leurs animaux
un temps fort pour valoriser l'adoption
responsable qui se fait également par le
biais d'une campagne empruntant les
codes du cinéma comme vous pouvez le
voir sur les affiches à l'écran
l'association a détourné plusieurs
affiches justement de films pour mettre
en lumière leur pensionnaires merci
beaucoup c'est Michard pour toutes ces
informations du jour et comme d'habitude
si vous avez vous voyez une information
ou une image qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
hashtag 7 8 news
au chapitre politique Aurore Bergé
député de la dixième circonscription à
des Yvelines et président du groupe
Renaissance à l'Assemblée nationale a
lancé une grande participation citoyenne
autour d'angeux clés des échanges autour
de la santé de la transition écologique
de l'école en présence divinois des
professionnels et d'élus la première
réunion s'est tenue la semaine dernière
à Maurepas Mélanie poquet et Céline
Charles l'ont rencontré à cette occasion
bonjour Alors on est ici à la mairie de
Maurepas c'est le premier devant
rendez-vous vous lancez une grande
participation citoyenne autour d'un
jeu-clés ce soir le premier rendez-vous
c'est au tour de la santé et l'autonomie
déjà pourquoi ces deux choix là déjà
parce que je pense que c'est un sujet
essentiel au quotidien
l'inquiétude de pas trouver un médecin
traitant l'angoisse de la perte
d'autonomie alors c'est à la fois la
question du handicap mais c'est aussi la
perte d'autonomie pour des proches des
personnes plus âgées nos parents et donc
l'idée c'est de parler de ce qui
intéresse le quotidien des gens et
d'essayer de aussi de confronter les
points donc c'est pour ça là on est
juste avant la réunion ne début se
démarrera dans une heure mais l'idée
c'est bien ça de confronter les points
de Dieu entre les citoyens des
professionnels de santé des médecins des
sages-femmes des infirmiers qui ont
accédé d'être avec nous et qui vont
pouvoir nous confronter un peu au réel
mais justement pourquoi confronter
toutes ces parties citoyens
professionnels élus ils doivent apporter
chacun leur regard oui parce que en tant
que citoyen on a des demandes on a des
attentes en tant que professionnelle de
santé on en a d'autres en tant qu’élus
on en a d'autres et puis on doit
partager aussi un niveau de contraintes
parfois on m'envoie des messages en
disant moi je sais ce qu'il faut faire
voilà comment on va sauver le système de
santé notre système à l'hôpital public
etc le fait qu'on partage ensemble à la
fois les attentes réelles les
inquiétudes qui peuvent exister des
contraintes et puis qu'on dégage
ensemble des solutions moi l'engagement
que je prends c'est aussi celui-ci de
dire que la participation citoyenne
c'est pas juste de réfléchir ensemble
c'est d'essayer de travailler sur des
solutions qu'ensuite moi en tant que
député en tant que présidente de groupe
à l'Assemblée je vais pouvoir
retranscrire dans la loi alors justement
je vous propose de les écouter
et je viens pour essayer de rétablir
certaines contre-vérités sur les
solutions soi-disant apporter aux
problèmes de pénurie médical à l'heure
actuelle en France qui ne trouveront
sûrement pas leur réponse dans la
coercition dans la quatrième année
imposée aux étudiants ils vont fuir
encore plus et ils ont raison je les
incite à fuir si c'est comme ça et sur
le toutes les contraintes
administratives qui vont nous être
imposées en plus alors qu'on est en
train d'en mourir et que c'est pour ça
qu'on nous a dégoûté d'exercer un métier
qu'on adore on est en train de
travailler avec le département et
l'Université de Saint-Quentin justement
pour faire que l'internat
en médecine de ville se déploie plus que
aujourd'hui
l'intérêt en fait il est double
renforcer la capacité médicale auprès de
nos médecins de ville qui connaissent
bien qui sont ancrées dans le tissu
communal et puis en espérant que les
étudiants qui sont dans cette commune se
mettent à l'apprécier
vient de prendre sa retraite et que j'ai
beaucoup de mal à prendre rendez-vous
avec un nouveau parce qu'en général il
ne peuvent pas prendre de nouveaux
patients alors vous l'avez dit la santé
c'est un sujet dont parle tous les jours
la crise de la covid a renforcé selon un
rapport d'information sénatoriale qui
était rendu en mars 2022 11% des
Français de plus de 17 ans n'ont pas de
médecin traitant ils sont 600 000 en ALD
affection longue durée nous espérons en
parler avec les participants justement
ce soir de cette ça inquiète de pas
pouvoir prendre rendez-vous parfois bien
sûr le jour J et puis médecin ça sera
urgence bien sûr prétendre bien sûr en
fait ce qui se passe au sein de nos
systèmes d'urgence et le président de la
République a dit se désengorgement qu'on
veut faire en un an de système notre
système d'urgence finalement c'est le
thermomètre de tout ce qui dysfonctionne
avant souvent qu'on va aux urgences on
ne va pas pour de bonnes raisons mais
parce qu'on n'a pas d'autre choix parce
qu'on se dit ok je sais que je devrais
pas venir pour ça mais je sais pas
comment faire autrement que de venir
vous voir donc ça met tout le monde dans
un inconfort les professionnels de santé
c'est ce qu'ils peuvent pas répondre
dans les bons délais aux demandes parce
qu'ils ont des métiers qui finissent par
des plaquer et qu'ils ont parfois plus
de 2000 patients dans le passé
évidemment tenir nous l'engagement qu'on
prend c'est de dire que tous ceux qui
sont en affection de longue durée qui
ont des maladies qui sont extrêmement
sévères des maladies chroniques qui sont
vous le savez pris en charge à 100% dans
notre système de santé notre système de
solidarité retrouve tous d'ici la fin de
l'année en médecine traitant ça c'est
l'engagement très clair qu'on a pris
parce qu'on ne peut pas les laisser sans
suivi médical quelles solutions
justement on peut mettre en place pour
ceci on va manquer de médecins le numéro
de clausus a longtemps freiner les
entrées il y a une année supplémentaire
pour les médecins généralistes ils ont
une quatrième année est-ce que ça part
tarder il faudrait presque 10 ans
rencontrer le résultat alors il y a
plusieurs choses qu'on a fait déjà le
numéro de clausus c'est fini et donc ça
veut dire que cette espèce de vieille
rengaine c'est fini mais est-ce que les
places en internat sont ouvertes
elles sont très largement ouvertes mais
le numéro exclusion ça a été créé à un
moment où on se que moins de médecins ça
ferait moins de dépenses de santé ben en
fait ça marche pas comme ça c'est à dire
qu'à un moment les maladies elles ont
aussi évoluées il y a eu plus de
maladies chroniques donc on a eu plus de
demandes donc le numéro de clausus on a
fait sauter ce verrou qui objectivement
n'avait aucun sens et c'était nécessaire
de pouvoir le faire on a fait monter
aussi en compétence d'autres professions
médicales qui ont moins d'années de
formation et qui peuvent non pas
remplacer le médecin c'est pas ça mais
qui peuvent réaliser un certain nombre
d'actes vous parlez d'un parcours de
soins presque c'est ça je pense par
exemple à nos sages-femmes on le voit
bien en tant que femme la difficulté de
trouver un gynécologue et bien on a la
quasi-totalité de nos actes à partir du
moment où ça n'est pas grave le suivi au
quotidien y compris le suivi d'une
grossesse qui peut être réalisée par la
sage-femme et donc on les a fait monter
en compétences de manière elle se soit
beaucoup plus autonome dans leurs actes
le pharmacien c'est un très bon exemple
avant le covid on pouvait pas se faire
vacciner chez son pharmacien aujourd'hui
ça paraît presque anodin mais non ça
n'était pas ça n'était pas possible on a
fait là aussi sauter pendant longtemps
vous ne pouvez pas se faire avec ce
n'est pas là maintenant qu'est-ce qui se
passe on va acheter son vaccin et en
fait on va se faire vacciner
immédiatement ce qui évite de perdre des
doses ce qui évite pour l'Assurance
Maladie de perte de l'argent et ce qui
est surtout beaucoup plus efficace pour
tout le monde il y a aussi des questions
de l'autonomie on l'a dit oui tout à
l'heure c'est un sujet là aussi primaire
en 2030 le nom de personnes en perte
d'autonomie en France atteindra 1,6
millions c'est 2,5 en 2060 quel serait
les solutions pour permettre aux gens de
ne pas perdre de tenue de rester chez
eux on sait que les épanouies
de personnes âgées veulent finir leur
vie chez elle est-ce que déjà vous avez
des pistes est-ce que vous espérez ce
soir trouver des pistes aussi c'est
l'objectif en tout cas évidemment de ce
genre de réunion et qui est un lieu
d'échange vous voyez bien me la
configuration l'idée c'est pas moi qui
parle oui c'est moi le travail justement
et confronté encore une fois les points
de vue après sur l'autonomie déjà on est
en train d'examiner une loi une
proposition de loi d'initiative de mon
groupe justement sur ce sujet parce
qu'on est passé en procédure accélérée
le 11 avril dernier on a n'a pas pu
finir mais on va finir dans quelques
semaines son examen et c'est une loi
importante notamment sur la lutte contre
la maltraitance en EHPAD il faut aussi
envoyer un message clair là-dessus parce
que oui il y a eu des scandales mais moi
je suis au quotidien j'échange avec
celles et ceux qui travaillent en EHPAD
plus on est en train de dire de dégrader
aussi l'image des EHPAD moins évidemment
je serai de vocation de gens qui auront
envie de travailler parce que ce qu'ils
m'ont dit ça m'avait beaucoup frappé
quand j'étais à l'olivier c'était bah
vous rendez compte donc pendant la crise
covid on nous applaudissait au balcon et
là maintenant nous insulte donc on passe
d'un extrême à l'autre il y a comme
partout malheureusement des gens qui
font mal leur travail mais qui sont très
minoritaires et leur évidemment quand ça
tombe sur quelqu'un qui est de votre
famille c'est absolument insupportable
c'est un digne et ça doit être
sanctionné et très durement sanctionné
mais la vérité c'est que ce sont souvent
des gens qui sont passionnés par leur
métier qui sont dans des métiers
pénibles dans des métiers difficiles
aussi évidemment il faut former plus
mais il faut aussi donner envie que ces
métiers soient exercés donc il faut
essayer de très vigilant sur l'image
qu'on renvoie de ces métiers et puis
après la question de est-ce que on
souhaite aller dans un lieu qui a un
lieu aussi collectif médicalisé parfois
on n'a pas d'autre choix parce qu'en
fonction des pathologies notamment
neurodégénératives quand vous êtes par
exemple atteint d'Alzheimer de manière
très significative vous avez des risques
qui sont importants et donc vous avez
besoin d'être dans un espace qui est
aussi sécurisé on le voit pour de
risques que des personnes par exemple
fugueux et ne savent pas en fait plus
qu'elles sont non plus leurs repères etc
donc c'est aussi pour le bien des
personnes parfois et c'est souvent très
douloureux pour les familles elles-mêmes
il faut faire ce choix de la
médicalisation mais quand on peut
adapter le logement alors on doit le
faire ça c'est ce qu'on veut faire c'est
l'engagement qu'on a pris avec ce qu'on
appelle ma prime adapt m'a appris ma
date c'est de faire en sorte que l'État
vienne vous soutenir dans toutes les
rénovations que vous avez à faire
dernière question est-ce qu’un
compte-rendu sera fait les propositions
seront montrées à remonter à François
Brown le ministre de la Santé au
président Emmanuel Macron alors moi
l'engagement que je prends c'est ça
c'est à dire c'est pas juste un lieu
d'échange et de débat c'est pour ça et
c'est utile de se reparler on voit bien
que dans le contexte parfois il y a de
la tension et c'est pas toujours facile
de se parler mais je pense que c'est
nécessaire qu'on aille au devant sur des
sujets qui sont des sujets de
préoccupation première des Français mais
oui c'est que les propositions qui
ressortiront de ces rendez-vous de ces
échanges avec les professionnels moi
évidemment je les remettrai au ministre
et puis si je peux moi-même les
retranscrire parce que c'est aussi notre
initiative parlementaire évidemment je
le ferai vous avez déjà une date pour
rendre ce compte rendu il faut déjà
qu'on travaille ce soir et après
évidemment avant l'été je souhaite que
les propositions au moins sur ce premier
thème puisse être bien précisé échanger
après avec les professionnels de santé
de manière à ce qu'elle puisse être
remise merci Aurore berger nous avons
accordé cet entretien
Aurore berger prévoit deux autres
rendez-vous le 25 mai autour de l'école
et le 16 juin autour de l'écologie et de
l'agriculture on reste sur la thématique
de la santé tout au long de la semaine
où vous proposons d'apprendre les gestes
de premier secours avec la croix blanche
créée en 1892 qui a pour mission
d'assurer la sécurité des populations
sur les rassemblements et de former au
secourisme dans ce premier module le
président départemental de l'association
croix blanche 78 Bernard dabas nous
explique que faire en cas d'obstruction
des voies aériennes un reportage de
Julien Leroy
[Musique]
sur cette séquence je vais vous montrer
la conduite à tenir face à une personne
qui a une obstruction complète des
voises aériennes tout en mangeant
j'arrive près de la victime et là la
victime a les mains à la gorge à la
bouche ouverte il y a aucun son qui
sorte Mathéo tu m'entends à ce moment-là
je vais laisser dans la position où il
se trouve pourra régir plus rapidement
je vais le pencher en avant tout en le
soutenant pour faciliter la sortie du
corps étranger et avec le talon de la
main je vais taper entre les omoplates
vigoureusement naturellement là je mime
jusqu'à 5 fois maximum si au bout de 5
fois c'est sorti on va le rassurer et
appeler si c'est pas sorti il faut
passer à une autre technique donc tout
en laissant la victime dans la position
où je l'ai trouvée je vais mettre à sa
même hauteur derrière elle passez mes
bras sous ses bras et mon point le dos
de la main vers le ciel je vais le
positionner juste au dessus du nombril
à votre ma part dessus mes bras écartés
et là en étant contre la chaise pour
avoir un plan dur je vais tirer vers moi
et remonter ce geste là va compresser
les poumons et donc faciliter la sortie
du corps étranger par un effet piston et
donc là la deuxième pareil 5 fois 2e
fois crash voilà et tout ça
voilà la victime tous elle est sortie
d'affaires on va la rassurer ne
t'inquiète pas ce qui t'empêchait de
respirer est sorti d'accord tu risques
plus rien ça va tu respires mieux ok bon
ben voilà et pour avoir un avis médical
car seul le médecin peut faire un
diagnostic et bien je vais téléphoner et
avoir un avis pas forcément pour qui se
déplace mais pour avoir un avis médical
si vous avez des questions ou si vous
avez besoin d'un avis médical n'hésitez
pas à composer le numéro d'urgence le 15
une personne nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau Sylvie d'agneau la responsable
du service des sports de la ville de
Magny-les-Hameaux vous venez pour nous
parler de la nouvelle édition du Défi
sport un événement organisé de ce
mercredi 26 à ce vendredi 28 avril au
gymnase Chantal Mauduit bonsoir alors
quel est le concept de cet événement le
concept c'est d'accueillir le plus
d'enfants possible
aussi bien jeune ado à partir de 6 ans
donc pour proposer et avoir trois jours
d'animation de loisirs avec des jeux
sous forme de réflexion ils veulent
participer à des jeux de grimpe des jeux
de relais l'idée c'est une notion de
partage et que ça soit ludique pour tous
alors je crois qu'il faut collecter un
des jetons en remportant des défis c'est
bien ça si j'ai bien compris l'idée un
peu c'est de bloquer des fois ces
partenaires et notion de stratégie qui
peut être mis en place avec l'équipe
alors qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait retrouver
comme le jeu vous l'avez dit habiter
logique précision c'est bien ça on a
aussi des structures gonflables aussi
beaucoup sur des jeux de relais on aura
un laser Game qui sera mis en place le
vendredi parce que le vendredi du coup
on accueille aussi les familles
l'après-midi jusqu'en soirée pour
partager cet temps fort avec les enfants
et on accueille aussi on a une
association la main tendue qui va être
présente et les fonds récoltés serviront
pour les aider justement dans leur
financement des maraude et comment se
déroule la journée si on veut y
participer on peut y aller tout le temps
on peut y aller aussi bien le matin donc
de 10h à midi ou de 14h à 16h ou la
journée voilà il y a pas de contraintes
d'inscription c'est libre au choix et
ils viennent quand ils veulent et quand
ils sont disponibles et pourquoi c'est
l'événement idéal à tester pour les
vacances selon vous pour nous on trouve
que c'est quand même quelque chose
d'original parce que en soit il y a
cette notion un petit peu de jeu un
petit peu interactif ludique
l'aidant du sport mais dans du sport de
loisirs et de partage si je me trompe
pas c'est la cinquième édition qu'est-ce
qui fait que ça fonctionne
l'année dernière pour vous donner un
petit peu un chemin en 2021 on avait à
peu près entre 300 et 400 personnes sur
les trois jours plus la soirée et
l'année dernière on est monté à 600
personnes et vous faites régulièrement
ce type d'opération on va essayer de le
maintenir jusqu'en 2024 bien évidemment
avec les JO et il y a une nocturne du
coup vous l'avez dit le vendredi 28
avril jusqu'à 21h et du coup qu'est-ce
qui change par rapport aux autres
les parents viennent avec leurs enfants
et peuvent participer et s'amuser entre
eux toute la soirée et manger sur place
s'ils le souhaitent Benjamin qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez de cette événement
c'est très bien c'est c'est une bonne
initiative parce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement il faut il
faut pratiquer le sport dès le plus
jeune âge avec tout ce qui s'est passé
ces dernières années on a été on a été
on s'est essayé dedansariser et il faut
il faut absolument bouger et en famille
encore mieux donc c'est une bonne
initiative bravo oui c'est vraiment un
événement familial si je comprends bien
on travaille aussi beaucoup en
partenariat avec d'autres services de la
ville bien évidemment le Service Enfance
et le service jeunesse qui sont aussi
l'un pour aider encadrer et participer à
cet événement au niveau de notre ville
on sent jamais forcément compte quand on
vient sur un événement ça met combien de
temps organiser un événement comme
celui-là qui va attirer plusieurs
centaines de personnes
un mois le temps aussi de la réflexion
de savoir aussi la thématique les choix
d'activité parce que l'idée aussi c'est
de trouver des choses qui correspondent
aussi à ce public jeune qui sont aussi
dans des attentes un petit peu on va
dire fun si vous me permettez
l'expression mais du coup voilà donc et
puis après de gérer tout ce qui est la
logistique aussi savoir un petit peu les
structures ce qu'on va trouver tout ce
qui événementiel comme vous connaissez
qui est pas forcément toujours facile
mais c'est quelque chose qui est
passionnant et qui nous passionne
vraiment au niveau du service des sports
et comment vous faites pour trouver
justement les animations on prospecte on
regarde un petit peu ce qui se passe
ailleurs enfin voilà et puis on a
l'avantage aussi nous on est labellisé
terre de jeu 2024 donc j'ai un éducateur
qui est référencé et qui est lui
porte-parole de ça et qui est aussi au
contact de beaucoup de prestataires pour
permettre justement d'avoir des contacts
pour des animations et quelle est
l'animation phare que tout le monde veut
faire absolument Laser Quest il y a
beaucoup de monde à chaque fois
ça attire beaucoup de jeunes cette
animation
oui Benjamin vous pourriez y aller
peut-être l'année prochaine on va
regarder les jeunes aiment bien être un
écran mais à faire du sport ça va
changer donc c'est bien merci à vous
d'être passé sur ce plateau le défi
sport 2023 commence demain à
Magny-les-Hameaux et se terminera ce
vendredi 28 avril on va maintenant
parler de votre concept Benjamin Edelin
alors je le rappelle vous êtes un ancien
pistard de l'équipe de France et vous
avez décidé de créer roule comme un
champion où on se met dans la peau d'un
cycliste sur piste c'est bien ça ouais
c'est ça l'idée c'est effectivement de
de partager un petit peu ce que j'ai
vécu pendant des des années c'est à dire
rouler sur un vélo drone alors la piste
c'est quelque chose qui est pas qui est
pas très connu donc donc voilà il y a
des applications qui nous permettent de
faire du vélo donc moi j'ai acheté tout
le matériel et puis maintenant je fais
découvrir aux gens bah voilà cette
pratique donc je vais dans les
entreprises je vais dans les foires dans
dans les animations je vais un petit peu
partout et l'idée effectivement c'est de
partager bon roule comme un champion
voilà c'est d'essayer de rouler comme un
champion alors je dis pas que ça va le
faire on va y arriver en deux jours mais
voilà l'idée c'est de promouvoir un
petit peu mon sport déjà parce que bah
c'est quelque chose qui me tient à cœur
et puis promouvoir le sport en général
donc voilà ça c'est hyper c'est hyper
important pour moi pour les jeunes pour
les moins jeunes aussi pour tout le
monde comment vous êtes nul l'idée vous
êtes très bien un matin et vous êtes dit
pourquoi pas non non j'ai discuté avec
avec un chef d'entreprise qui est qui
est un très grand chef d'entreprise et
il m'a demandé si j'avais des idées pour
pour l'esprit d'équipe voilà pour pour
partager un moment avec ces
collaborateurs et puis c'était quelqu'un
qui qui aimait beaucoup le sport et je
lui dis mais attends moi je peux
peut-être t'aider à faire quelque chose
et donc du coup voilà c'est parti comme
ça je j'ai investi j'ai partagé un petit
peu de temps avec lui pour savoir ce
qu'il voulait puis après j'ai travaillé
puis bah j'ai fait mon premier événement
avec lui j'ai vu que ça s'était très
bien passé il y avait eu des retours
très très positifs et donc du coup j'ai
commencé à démarcher à regarder un petit
peu comment comment je peux voler faire
évoluer tout ça et finalement il y a de
la demande parce que au fur et à mesure
des des années avec le télétravail avec
tout ce qui s'est passé il y a des
entreprises aujourd'hui ou dans les
bureaux on se voit presque plus donc
l'esprit d'équipe il existe pas le
contact humain on l'a pas non plus et
puis ben voilà ça fait du bien aussi de
se retrouver à un moment dans autre
qu'une autour d'une table en train de
discuter de projet derrière des
ordinateurs là on passe un moment
derrière on peut manger boire quelque
chose et puis et puis voilà profiter
ensemble ça crée des liens Marion va
parler du musée du jouet dans quelques
minutes qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de
ce concept de Benjamin
l'occasion de parler de sport aussi au
musée donc c'est des choses qui nous
intéressent également et on prépare pour
les pour les JO une exposition sur les
jouets le sport donc Sylvie ça pourrait
vous intéresser ou pour manier
le contact est pris alors est-ce que
c'est vraiment réaliste oui alors
forcément oui sur l'effort physique bon
vous l'avez testé oui on l'a testé
encore on a fait que deux tours
78 alors on n'a pas toute l'équipe en
images qui a testé moi j'ai pu tester et
c'est vrai que c'est plutôt réaliste
voilà on voit que l'effort il peut être
intense et en tout cas on le voit au jeu
donc forcément c'est là c'était sous
forme de petites compétition donc
forcément on a donné un petit peu bah
tout ce qu'on avait
je pense que ce genre de ce genre de
projet de toute façon il est il est il
est positif parce que tout le monde
partage on fait un effort physique
est-ce qu'on a toutes les le ressenti
piste bien veut dire que non parce que
sur une piste vous à 50 ans en Yvelines
au Vélodrome de national de 50 ans en
Yvelines nous on est sur des virages qui
font 8 mètres de haut qui sont inclinés
à 44 degrés donc bien sûr que c'est pas
pareil ça a assez c'est un avant-goût si
ça peut vous permettre derrière de venir
faire un baptême au Vélodrome avec
plaisir parce que là vous allez avoir
les vrais sensations que que j'ai vécu
que d'autres sportifs ont actuellement
et c'est quelque chose vraiment de
d'extraordinaire oui justement
l'objectif c'est vraiment de créer
peut-être un déclic chez ces
participants ouais bah moi je promouvois
mon sport donc mon sport c'est le
cyclisme sur piste donc je fais en sorte
effectivement que que les gens viennent
au Vélodrome moi je suis coach mon
métier c'est d'être coach aussi donc je
travaille pour le vélo Drôme de
Saint-Quentin et j'ai des gens qui
viennent tous les samedis tous les
mercredis faire faire des baptêmes qui
derrière prennent des abonnements qui
reviennent qui prennent leurs pieds
clairement on s'est vite grisant il y a
une sensation de vitesse il y a voilà il
y a aussi une sensation de de réussite
vous arrivez vous voyez les virages vous
dites jamais je tiendrai ici et
finalement au bout d'une vous êtes tout
en haut en train de rouler à plus de 40
km/h parce qu'on roule très très
rapidement à ces allures là donc non moi
voilà je promouvois là je mets le pied à
l'étrier en même temps avec ce projet et
c'est vraiment ce que ce que j'apprécie
oui vous êtes content de votre
reconversion Benjamin ouais ouais bien
sûr ouais je suis je suis très content
parce que je suis resté je suis resté
dans mon domaine que que j'aime
aujourd'hui je prends encore énormément
de plaisir même si c'est plus du tout la
même chose là avant je voyais je faisais
des compétitions j'avais voilà
l'adrénaline de tout ça maintenant
j'entraîne alors je fais j'entraîne
aussi du haut niveau des des voilà des
des jeunes et des moins jeunes qui qui
font mon sport bon voilà j'ai plusieurs
j'ai plusieurs flèches à mon arc et je
jongle entre tout ça mais je m'amuse je
m'amusais énormément et quels sont les
réactions des participants à la fin ils
ont mal ouais alors oui déjà ouais ils
ont mal alors souvent c'est c'est assez
c'est assez sympathique parce que voilà
il y a eu cet esprit de compétition donc
tout le monde se félicite il y a aussi
il y a aussi les gens derrière qui voit
ce qui se passe sur les écrans donc qui
peuvent qui peuvent confirmergir ça fait
mal vraiment ouais c'est assez difficile
mais voilà c'est c'est quand même un
esprit c'est un esprit sympathique là on
a fait des petites courses de 40
secondes on pourrait faire des courses
d'une heure de 1h30 on peut tout faire
on est libre donc non on peut vraiment
on peut vraiment s'amuser ouais et les
pista il réagissent comment j'ai donc
j'ai un ami qui l'a fait et bon alors
bien sûr il a il a explosé les records
donc je me base sur lui pour dire s'il y
a un champion à en venir mais non ouais
il réagissent en disant que l'effort est
intense parce qu'en fait le seul vélo en
fonction de en fonction de ce que vous
mettez sur sur les pédales la puissance
que vous développez en fait votre avatar
réagit donc même si vous êtes
extrêmement fort lui il va adapter la
résistance par rapport à ce que vous
avez devant vous avez aussi l'effet
d'aspiration donc si vous êtes dans la
route quelqu'un c'est un petit peu plus
facile le vélo vous relâche de l'effort
donc voilà on a une on a une simulation
proche plus proche de la réalité sauf
qu'on n'a pas l'aspect technique de
piloter quoi un vélo donc il faut savoir
faire du vélo pour faire de la piste
bien entendu donc nous là même si vous
savez pas faire vous avez l'équilibre
donc c'est accessible à tout le monde
c'est ce côté innovant à mon fin de
compte qui peut être hyper intéressant
justement par rapport au public jeune
qui ne connaissent pas forcément non
plus cette activité parce que bon c'est
pas dit à tout le monde aussi d'avoir un
vélo de route dans sa ville on va dire
et je trouve que justement c'est une
très très bonne idée pour donner goût
aussi peut-être à ce jeune assez public
là quoi mais c'est pas très loin de
maniable vous pouvez peut-être tester et
si on veut tester ce concept justement
comment ça se passe bah alors là pour
l'instant je suis en train de créer mon
site internet donc merci pour cette
question qui va qui va se terminer là
normalement dans la dans la semaine ou
semaine prochaine donc roule comme un
champion.com ça va arriver très
prochainement ou sinon pour l'instant
bah sur par Gmail par mail rôle comme un
champion@gmail.com donc là je reçois un
petit peu tout et puis pour l'instant je
fais un petit peu comme madame je voilà
je discute j'échange je suis dans le
partage de ma passion et donc du coup
bah de temps en temps je rencontre des
personnes intéressées voilà c'est c'est
le bouche-à-oreille pour l'instant qui
fait que que ça fonctionne merci
beaucoup
on a compris il y a une prise de contact
entre Manille et amo et vous on verra ça
dans les prochains mois personnellement
alors moi j'ai bien envie d'essayer à
nouveau alors je digère toujours pas ma
défaite contre l'un des monteurs de tv78
Thomas Fletcher alors j'espère retenter
ma chance dans les prochains mois avec
plaisir alors on va maintenant ouvrir
une page culture dans le 7 8
[Musique]
dans cette page culture retour sur une
exposition inédite le château de Ternay
à Fontenay-le-Fleury accueilli ce
week-end une exposition intitulée
mettait compter mettant à l'honneur le
dramaturge et cinéaste français Sacha a
dit tri à un reportage de Grégory
canalet et lui divine canard le château
de terre rarement ses portes mais le
cours Sainte-Clotilde d'une école tenue
par une congrégation dominicaine n'a pas
hésité à les ouvrir pour accueillir
cette exposition l'idée faire revivre le
dramaturge et cinéaste français Sacha
Guitry dans sa résidence secondaire il a
acquis la maison que vous voyez derrière
nous en 1937 jusqu'à sa mort il y a vécu
jusqu'à sa mort en 1957 dans le grand
salon au rez-de-chaussée et vous pourrez
découvrir que Sacha Guitry était un
grand artiste trois pièces du château
ont été aménagées pour découvrir les
différents visages de Sacha Guitry d'un
côté cinéaste artiste mais aussi
comédien et réalisateur des tableaux des
photographies des dessins de sa main et
des manuscrits permettent de retracer la
vie de ce personnage 1000 casquettes des
objets personnels de l'artiste prêté par
la Bibliothèque historique de la Ville
de Paris l'écrivain Yann Moix le
manuscrit français et même la société
Pathé un parcours animé par des pièces
de théâtre jouées par les élèves de
Première en spécialité histoire de l'art
de l'école c'est un souvenir auquel je
tiens énormément les 12 élèves se sont
préparés toute l'année pour cette
exposition on a préparé des petits
textes que l'on peut voir dans les
livrets de l'exposition donc sur ces
particularités de Sacha Guitry puis
pour préparer la l'exposition on a créé
donc tous les petits cartels
d'exposition avec les descriptifs à
chaque fois les visiteurs ont pu
profiter de l'espace extérieur
transformé à l'époque en zoo par Sacha
Guitry voir le parc que nous avions vu
seulement en photo nous sembler
indispensable pour voir ce que renfermer
cette écrin derrière les grands murs et
nous avons été impressionnés par la
beauté de l'exposition prochaine porte
ouverte du château les journées du
patrimoine en septembre prochain
nous allons maintenant parler du Musée
du Jouet de Poissy avec vous Marion
Abadie alors vous êtes attachés de
conservation dans la structure le Musée
du Jouet propose plusieurs activités
pendant les vacances il y aura notamment
des ateliers pour les 4-6 ans et 7 12
ans avec fabrication de marionnettes des
origamis des échasses est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un petit peu plus
bien sûr on propose à chaque vacances on
fête des ateliers très très variés qui
s'adressent aux quatre saisons et aux 7
7 12 après il y a parfois des ateliers
pour des âges intermédiaires qui sont en
général en lien avec les collections du
musée qui font des petits clins d'oeil
aux collections et donc cette cette pour
ces vacances là on propose beaucoup de
choses notamment des ateliers en lien
avec l'exposition qui est actuellement
présentée au musée et voilà donc les
enfants viennent s'amuser pendant une
heure et demie deux heures et repartent
avec un objet qu'ils ont fabriqué un
petit jeu ou un petit jouet qui sont
fabriqués en atelier alors mardi
prochain il y aura un événement tourne
tourne mon moulin la découverte de la
mise en mouvement d'un jouet en créant
un moulin avant un jeu très apprécié à
l'époque médiévale c'est je dis ça
l'idée l'objectif du Musée du Jouet de
recréer des scènes peut-être qui
existent de transmettre en fait un
patrimoine qui est un patrimoine modeste
qui est celui du jouet qui a toute une
histoire effectivement les petits
moulins en fait ce sont des jeux qu'on
voit sur des tableaux du Moyen-Âge sur
des tableaux du 17e du 15e du 16e et du
17e siècle aussi et donc on rentre en
fait dans cette histoire par la petite
porte en fabriquant ses jouets qui
amusent toujours les enfants qui sont
tout bêtes un petit moulin en papier
qu'on va faire qu'on va faire tourner en
soufflant dessus ou en le le sortant
dehors au vent et voilà les enfants
d'aujourd'hui s'amusent autant que les
enfants d'autrefois avec ce type de
jouets est-ce que les enfants ont recréé
plus ou moins ce qui se passait à
l'époque alors non là c'est vraiment la
création avec des matériaux
d'aujourd'hui et colorier par les
enfants etc donc c'est une une reddition
actuelle en fait de des jouets
d'autrefois
plus insolites à tester pendant ces
vacances
un atelier qui est qui est le dernier de
l'année là qui s'appelle l'atelier de
pelucheologie alors c'est un atelier
assez court en fait on vient quand on
veut dans l'après-midi la lieu demain le
dernier c'est l'atelier de pelucheologie
donc les enfants viennent avec leur
peluche et en fait on les initie à un
peu importe la peluche qui souhaite ils
viennent avec et on va les initier en
fait à ce que c'est que l'inventaire
donc c'est une science des musées mais
c'est aussi une science de sciences
naturelles inventorier la faune la flore
et on va leur apprendre à mesurer à
définir leur peluche et ça va rentrer
dans un grand inventaire des peluches
qui avaient été initié par l'Université
de Montpellier voilà donc c'est ce mot
assez drôle la peluchologie qui permet
en fait une vraie initiation
scientifique si on veut le tester si je
comprends bien c'est la dernière fois
alors c'est la dernière demain
après-midi et c'est en lien avec notre
exposition petite bête de tout poils qui
qui est présentée depuis quelques mois
qui dure jusqu'à l'été donc ce mercredi
a testé absolument si vous voulez sinon
ça sera
en général sur les ateliers où est-ce
qu'on va dire on change pas une recette
qui gagne évidemment des recettes il y a
des classiques qu'on retrouve et que les
enfants tiennent à retrouver
régulièrement il y a aussi des choses
nouvelles voilà qui peuvent changer un
petit peu alors par exemple
la semaine prochaine il y a un atelier
pour les plus grands parce que là ça
s'adresse il faut avoir une certaine
adresse on va dire c'est l'atelier des
chasse donc là aussi c'est quelque chose
de très pour les 7 non c'est pour les
7-12 ans 8 8 14 ans je crois que c'est
un peu plus grand une 14 ans et donc là
ils sont initiés par des spécialistes en
fait et ce sont vraiment des grandes
échases en fait donc c'est un peu
impressionnant mais voilà c'est c'est
adapté pour les enfants et je pense que
ça peut être amusant pour les pré-ados
notamment voilà c'est quelque chose qui
change alors les ateliers dure en
moyenne entre 1h30 à 2h pourquoi alors
1h30 c'est le minimum pour réussir à
fabriquer quelque chose c'est adapter
pour des petits qui ont un temps de
concentration plus limité donc 1h30 2h
c'est un maximum après on peut avoir des
ateliers qui durent 2 trois heures mais
c'est plus rare c'est quand ça demande
vraiment une fabrication longue alors
vous travaillez aussi avec des
plasticiens sur ces ateliers c'est un
plus oui c'est un plus on fait appel
aussi à des plasticiens extérieurs en
fait ça permet un petit peu de
renouveler les les propositions alors il
y a l'exposition on va terminer par ça
l'exposition un petit bête de tout poils
vous avez rapidement évoqué cette
exposition avant une exposition qui est
présentée jusqu'au 9 juillet on peut la
découvrir aussi pendant ses vacances
alors tout à fait elle est accessible en
permanence donc on vous invite vraiment
à venir la découvrir et c'est une
exposition qui est centrée sur le les
jouets animaliers donc tout ce qu'on
peut découvrir comme animaux on a appelé
ça petite bête de tout poil donc c'est
pas uniquement des peluches c'est
vraiment tous les animaux qu'on trouve
dans le jouet et effectivement depuis
l'Antiquité on a des jouets en argile
qui représentent des petits animaux à
roulettes par exemple et on peut
traverser comme ça les siècles avec tous
les jouets que ceux qu'on a connu aussi
jusqu'à des peluches très récentes par
exemple des animaux des animaux de jeux
vidéo également les prochaines
expositions alors la prochaine
exposition
ce sera sur un comment dire un une
bdculte de notre enfance qui est tomtom
et nana qui vont s'inviter au musée du
jouet à partir de l'automne prochain
avec le la période covid évidemment qui
a été un petit peu compliqué mais là on
retrouve nos chiffres de fréquentation
de d'avancer de période Merci à VOUS
Marion Abadie tous les renseignements
sont à retrouver sur la page Facebook du
musée du jouet ou sur le site internet
de la ville de Poissy c'est bientôt la
fin de cette émission mais juste avant
de se quitter jetons un dernier coup
d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
le temps sera une nouvelle fois nuageux
demain matin dans tout le département
selon la météo France au niveau des
températures il faut encore un peu frais
le matin le temps sera quasi automnale
n'hésitez pas à prendre une petite
écharpe avant de partir compter 8 degrés
aux dents et 7 degrés à Versailles
Mantes-la-Jolie et Rambouillet
l'après-midi la météo va se dégrader
sortez vos parapluies vos bottes il va
pleuvoir sur l'ensemble du département
et côté température les températures
aussi entre 13 et 14 degrés dans tout le
département il faudra encore un peu
patienter encore patienter quelques
jours pour pouvoir profiter pleinement
du printemps et demain nous fêterons la
sainte Alida c'est déjà la fin de ce 7 8
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
demain pour une nouvelle édition belle
soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]